Donald Trump at NATO was an
embarrassment to the United States of
America Donald Trump had this endless
series of weird and bizarre moments at
NATO in Brussels Belgium last week and
when I say embarrassing these would have
been embarrassing moments to a normal
person capable of being embarrassed
we're not sure actually if Donald Trump
falls under under that umbrella or not
so before taking the NATO Heads of State
photo on a stage and we've got some
pictures I'm going to walk you through
here all of the leaders were standing
around sort of talking to one another
but according to a report Trump just
stood there silently standing in the
centre without talking to anybody just
kind of awkwardly looking around
completely unable to interact with other
world leaders in any reasonable way my
sense is he didn't have too many friends
on that stage and someone off to the
side came up to take a picture and the
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
said everybody wave and everybody waves
this is really just no big deal except
for Donald Trump Donald Trump is the one
guy on the stage who just refuses to
even react like he has any sense of
what's going on around him the photo was
taken which which is the photo that I'm
showing you and afterwards the heads of
state sort of continued to talk to one
another but apparently nobody came up to
talk to Donald Trump and at one point
the NATO leaders were standing around in
a hallway and the press were
photographing them and Donald Trump was
kind of tucked in the back where the
cameras couldn't really see him as you
can see in this picture Trump's kind of
in the back there so what does Trump do
he shoves the president of Montenegro
Phillip via Novik out of the way so that
he's all of a sudden standing at the
front of the crowd and he kind of
adjusts his suit I'm going to play the
eight second clip for you now
yes and then a justice suit I've never
even heard of Montenegro what is that
some low-energy sad country get out of
my way it's just as the same thing as
him talking on and on again about how he
won the presidential election yeah it's
like he still has to prove something and
for a guy from Montenegro a country
probably never even heard about yet like
in front of him it just wasn't going to
happen he was not going to be he was not
going to be covered up by the president
of Montenegro so then from gives an
embarrassing speech rehashing one of his
lines from the campaign and he again
talked at the summit about how NATO
states aren't paying their fair share
these great security concerns are the
same reason that I have been very very
direct with secretary Stoltenberg and
members of the Alliance in saying that
NATO members must finally contribute
their fair share and meet their
financial obligations
so what's Trump talking about here Trump
is complaining that the US and four
other NATO member nations spend two
percent of their GDP on NATO and that
other countries pay less now the thing
is this entire two percent thing has not
been endorsed by any heads of state the
u.s. chooses to pay two percent the u.s.
can't tell other countries how to spend
on the military and this has not spent
this has not cost the u.s. more money
it's not a NATO rule Trump is pretending
it's a NATO rule truncus by the way are
falling for it but as Gary J Schmidt
said a scholar at the conservative
American Enterprise Institute quote he
doesn't care whether it's technically
accurate and it tends to burry the point
to bury the point that we're invested in
European security for our own strategic
reasons Trump making a fool out of
himself in front of these other world
leaders with this routine well I saw
that NATO members agreed in 2014 to
start working towards spending 2% of the
GDP on defense yeah but it's only 2017
now it's only been three years and that
was supposed to be a ten-year period at
the NATO summit Trump also was refusing
to support our
five of the NATO treaty Article five
states that all NATO member nations will
come to the defense of any single NATO
nation if they're under attack
ever since NATO was created in 1949
every single US president has supported
this article every president since Harry
Truman it's sort of one of the main
points of NATO and people are concerned
that Trump has been reluctant to support
that article and that it has something
to do with Russia which is one of NATO's
biggest adversaries Russia's surrounded
by NATO countries to the west if Russia
were to invade one of those countries
like it did Ukraine which is not a NATO
country then all of the other NATO
countries would presumably come to the
defense of that country and Trump
apparently may not want that to happen
so Trump is complaining about other NATO
countries not pulling their own weight
when it comes to something that is not
actually a NATO rule the 2% thing the
u.s. is actually the one that looks like
they're not the team player by not
saying hey we support Article five and
of course the only time that articles
side was ever invoked was after 9/11 and
it was for our benefit so how could you
not respond in kind if they were to be
attacked absolutely Trump needs to get
with the program when it comes to NATO
it's embarrassing and have you noticed
that Trump seems to enjoy himself a lot
more when he's meeting with the Russians
and the Saudis amongst his NATO
colleagues he did not seem to be having
as good of a time I'll remind you here
is Donald Trump with the Russians in the
Oval Office same day he spilled secret
info to them seems like a party with
suspected Russian spy recruiter Sergey
kis lyac and then here's Donald Trump
laughing it up in Saudi Arabia where he
actually danced he danced with the the
Saudis of Saudi diplomats officials
called him what you want and then he
meets with NATO allies and it's not
clear whether he's annoying annoyed or
confused about what's going on around
him but needless to say not having a
very good time embarrassing Donald Trump
truly making the u.s. the NATO
laughingstock in Brussels send me your
thoughts about this I'm on twitter at
des Pakman